think addict's frustration is and i
understand this point is to the to those
big blockbuster titles that xbox seems
to be missing i saw the show differently
right and i saw it different too like
i'm allegedly from from his from his
aspect i see your frustration i hear
your frustration but i can also um
put that to the side
right i can actually put my frustration
to the side and say that you guys are
trying in this area right yeah the
localization is huge a lot of times the
localization was wrong that's a huge
deal it was it was a problem huge deal
okay so when you're not trying to sell
somebody a console and you're trying to
sell them a subscription
it's a whole lot palaceable
15 a month ten dollars whatever they're
doing over there right right i don't
know the price uh
excuse me it's probably situation
but they have their cell phones
when you can turn your cell phone into a
gaming device
or you can stream it to your tv turn
your tv into the same gaming device that
you're playing on your console
that changes how you see it they was
trying to sell
surfaces
if they have laptops and moving laptops
they understand microsoft they
understand surface the duos duals you
know they're they're selling this
remember
xbox wants to reach that billion those
those those people
they're not going to do it by selling
xboxes physical xboxes to them i mean
and that's not even little man's not
even little not even
i mean you can always go to the
the
the youtube
comment section that that is for the
live stream and translate some of those
those comments and see what people are
saying because i'm telling you it it's
not as is is gravy as people be thinking
it's not like you know
they're not trying to reach that person
that's watching the live stream
they're not trying to reach that they're
trying to reach the comments
about that so at e3 they're not trying
to reach us no no let me let me explain
that's fan service i always say it's fan
service software
and tgs is fan service this is fan
service this is for us we are the trend
setters right when we talk to community
we're talking when people are watching
you do your show and you're giving your
fan serve you're telling them yo they
did this and they did that you are
informing the public
you are doing that but what they what
they're trying to do is have an app on a
tv an app on their phone and ship an app
on their surface or their computer when
it ships and then they hit the
application that's this over here that's
not even
the number one selling console in japan
we got to verify that okay even if that
is true on amazon though that relative
to what to what yeah
that's fantastic but when they say
you know the the series s or xbox is
selling more than it ever has in japan
there's a caveat to that right
i'm just saying
there was a week that it was literally
like i think they sold like 250 or some
stuff like that and it's like oh the
greatest yeah
and that's my thing it's like you know
people know i'm being stereotyped like
no man like like we can't see her and
act like the japanese support don't be
lacking like i gotta play final fantasy
7 on my playstation i have had to play
persona on my playstation right i've had
to play all the dragon quests up to this
last one on my playstation and guess
what when i do play stuff on my xbox
it's two to three years after the damn
game
but this goes back yeah and i feel that
completely the thing about it is i i
honestly think phil and the team have
been trying but when it comes to that
it just seems playstations have cemented
those deals years in advance right they
don't care what the next
with the next final fantasy looks like
we're getting it even if it comes out
and it's a trash fire we got it first
and then we gotta be we gotta be real
about the elephant in the room which is
japanese companies dealing with other
japanese companies we can't act like
you know right
microsoft just recently came up on a
list as far as from an international
standpoint of like on one of the most
hated lists right so you got that
barrier with a region that doesn't
necessarily want to be receptive to your
products right let me let me jump
because this is great attic is right i'm
not he's right i'm not trying to go at
him like he is right xbox is missing out
on too many of these big games where
it's late in first but i'm with solving
king
one i am seeing the committed effort
right the consistent effort i told
people the yakuza like a dragon thing
was huge at launch and people wasn't
paying me no money that's why i went out
supported i get mad
yeah with xbox fans like yo i ain't
playing rand i love you right now though
you're mad at you the treatment player
but um at the end of the day you know
it's one of those things where i know
that's something you don't see when lost
judgment is coming out at the same time
that's something you don't see but i
think that my biggest problem cog is i'm
tired of seeing a fire trailer on
something at the end of that trailer to
switch your play station
let me i know
let me let me finish let me tell you
what i think it's different this time
the reason why i'm a little bit more
confident this time with phil being in
the region is one
you gotta look at first
if you don't respect the language of of
the country country that you're trying
to be in
you already that's so that's why again
the localization was one big to me these
are small building blocks to get to
where you need to be very big on respect
right that's respecting the culture you
ain't even got the games in the language
or the culture you you don't even need
to beat it then the second thing what i
like that they did they launched the x
cloud i'm not saying oh my god just
because they got xcloud that's the game
changer i'm not saying i'm just saying
we do know it's a mobile region a lot we
do know people playing a phone that
again a building block right the next
thing to me that nobody's talking about
is what idea at xbox is doing with sarah
she was like look we are working with
japanese independent developers see to
me that's on the grass root level now
you get the next young star to debut his
joint the in-game pass that was my
second point okay
yeah where playstation built these bonds
with konami with um square and all these
games if you can build bonds with people
that are just starting you're giving
somebody they just start their new start
you're building them up from the bottom
there's a loyalty there it's it's crazy
and the fact that they put
listens
game pass somebody's hit me up so much
because i was saying uh phil is the the
reason for gamepad yeah sarah bond does
a lot there and that's that's the next
topic there later but this idea of xbox
her in in this space
he's going to grow this space something
crazy and i think
grabbing them early like you said fresh
out
your game going put you in a spot like
i think that means a lot yeah that's the
ball you've got it's like the street
team it's the grassroots you have to
well i like this approach because you
just can't go over there in my opinion
and just throw money at the big game and
they did that in the 360 generation i
think yeah
uh just recently this past week i think
a week before
colin and the guys the sacred symbols
got a lot of flack for some stuff that
they said that was preceded
yes
yeah and and the thing about it is they
were talking about you know
not wanting xbox to keep purchasing
publishers per se because that takes a
lot of a lot of teams off the table
and what happens is depending on who you
go out especially if you go out and
purchase japanese publishers if you
purchase the japanese publishers there's
going to be a lot of pushback from the
community on that it just will be
because again you're inherently
purchasing a publisher you're the
outsider on the surface exactly
you're muscling in one of the most hated
rated companies in in in the world
internationally and not that necessarily
they deserve that
no i don't know you don't care
what are you buying your favorite
pushback is so bad yeah that they can
kill those franchises we ain't gonna
kill them listen we're gonna cultivate
them cultivate that's what i think they
can they can be mad as you want you
could be all upset as you like mm-hmm
all right so you gonna still support i
don't care what it is you could say
whatever you want all these dudes that
was out there oh potential
you're still gonna buy
if if they purchase square enix
oh you're just trying to speak your
words into existence that you don't want
to happen all right but when microsoft
put that eye on your girl
she going home with us
this is not your situation but listen
i'll give you all that but
approach which is one grassroots indies
location all that stuff right you need
that then you do the game pass deals
right you get the third party launch and
get that on your service right you get
that popping i do agree with attic on
this though i do feel there needs to be
a commitment on a studio level so that
to me the bethesda thing gave them tango
by proxy right right but now they also
need
a home grown joint for themselves
and i'm with them on that yeah i think
that's my biggest thing it's like how do
you expect that market to take you
seriously when you're gonna have like a
studio in that marketplace
and i get it people want to count tango
and tango is a studio yeah but it's just
like to me it's just like they didn't go
out and buy tango by themselves
when you see the significance of what's
his name
on stage with phil and that's in it's in
the house right you can't tell me that
he ain't got shinji mikami and got dumb
relationships in the region so if they
do decide oh no that that's definitely
right so i think i love the look of them
two on stage you get to talk about the
future talk about things
and then we let's talk about the
elephant in the room we all know let's
be honest kajima is coming on some level
that's right so like it's it's they're
doing it it's just do we is it at the
level we want no we of course wanted to
be a slogan it's a slow burn with this
one bro it's gonna take time but i like
the fact that they are doing it i'm
talking about kojima game awards
[Music]
yeah i think when it comes to me man
it's just like i'm tired of that like
[Music]
right way like coming from someone like
me that loves final fantasy i get that
like to finally get my hands on the
franchises oh i can finally play that on
xbox and the band they gone one day like
it's just like it's just like it's i'm
just tired of the nonsense that's what
that change gonna come
what change is
a change going on
you're getting a 10 year
they didn't have change and we wake up
and we wake up we got tigger it was one
day yakuza games was never on the joint
we wake up we got you cool
they got tangled they got dragon's quest
that would never
oh